hey Tom people this is the Reuben report
I'm Jan Brewers spiritual guru Dave
Rubin and I have to to time repeat Rubin
report guests Wendy Liebman
and brett erlich and let's get to it so
you guys might have heard about this
little nutty law in Arizona it is
sb-1062 and this has passed the Arizona
Legislature and this allows businesses
as long as they assert their religious
beliefs to refuse service to customers
and now basically this means if you're
gay and they don't like you they don't
have to serve you so just real quick on
this thing because Jan Brewer may veto
this thing by the time we finish this
conversation she may not be told she
tweeted last night that she's going to
do what's best for Arizona I don't know
what the hell that means what is going
on in Arizona what is happening in that
kooky state you're trying to eliminate
the illegal alien gay people from going
that's a lot of Republican buzzwords in
one thing that you think that what
they're doing is they're cutting out
some of their business yeah it's
ridiculous on every level
yeah Republicans they love business
isn't this just the stupidest thing
possible wouldn't you want business they
love money it's this amazing place to be
caught between these two conflicting
fetishes of like business success and
and hate and hating certain individual
III think that uh I'm behind anything
that makes sure that gay people don't
get certain kinds of chicken sandwiches
yeah I just don't think that like you
know John's chicken sandwich should ever
serve a gay person yeah you know the
trucks don't want those fried chicken
sandwiches actually a huge opportunity
to put weird stuff in people's
sandwiches you know like you know if you
why don't you let them in allow them to
order and just do weird stuff to their
food
yeah that's your American right I say it
is should we give a little not be so
glib about what the religious people
want you know what I mean the Christian
Right says they're under attack and if
they have a religious belief that they
don't want to serve gay people because
they're insane
we have any respect for that in 2014 no
and I think we're gonna put Brett's
picture up on the wall of these
establishments oh no it's the other way
around yeah no because the Abbi
oh I'm the - storm you know what I'm
gonna go with you so the Abbi
I'll talk to the camera for a second so
the Abby which is basically the most
famous gay bar in the United States
certainly in California it is right in
West Hollywood right where I live they
have announced that they are going to
ban people who back
this legislation legislators who back
this legislation we have a quote from
the founder of the abbey this is from
Dave Cooley who owns the abbey he says I
want to send a message to all those
people out there who conflate Christian
values with discrimination we don't want
your kind here I've learned that I can't
stop crazy ignorant or stupid but I can
stop it from coming through my doors and
he's literally going to show mug shots
of these legislators not that these
people are going to show up at the Abbey
would they well which headshot obviously
will be there you never know because it
seems like the most homophobic or the
most hypocritical yeah so so you think
they might be showing up there in drag
perhaps or toe-tapping or something I
don't know I just think it's so funny
that anybody would discriminate from
getting any kind of business yeah I
don't understand that and in this
economy yeah yeah I think I think they
should leave the photos up so we know
the names and faces of the anti-gay
legislators but if they're coming to the
Abbey I think you should let them in let
them get a few in them
yeah maybe have some drinks yeah and
then take some photos
yeah of them and you know yeah and then
before and after you know I'm just
saying like if they're coming to the
Abbey and they're an anti-gay agent
legislature told you one photo evidence
of them being in your establishment
right and enjoying you know you know a
little sailor Jerry maybe it may be a
rum and coke yeah now obviously the
owners being he's being a little tongue
in cheek because these people most
likely are
showing up there but is there a risk in
gays becoming as sort of intolerant of
different views as the Christian right
that were always fighting against you
know what I mean if no both times I like
it yeah no I mean you're attacking
somebody's human right to exclude them
from going into any place so no you know
except for me like I there's some part
of me that says hey you know what if
there's a gay established gay right
establishment that doesn't want anti-age
legislators into their place I think
that's hilarious and awesome for them to
not let them come in but then again that
is the same thing as the other side
saying listen if I don't like gay people
then it's it's not the same thing
because the first person in the first
picture that I just painted that person
has transgressed by discriminating play
but you know if it's your place I'm
sorry but but like if it's my place and
I there's some people that I went to
high school with it I don't want to come
to my house yeah why can't I say you
can't come here so to that point though
so these people who say it's my business
I should be allowed to do what I want
they're bigots and then don't give them
your business should this be something
that's like legislature that's the part
to me of course you shouldn't be allowed
to discriminate against gay people but
then to me it's like gay people just
shouldn't go there like let chick-fil-a
exist and I'm not gonna eat chick-fil-a
there should just be a separate Yelp
called hey Benson you know a big X shows
up through the one you're going to I
mean let them do it I just think in the
end everyone's every you know the
everyone who bans gay people from coming
you through their doors is gonna get
enough negative press as a result I
don't think more people are gonna say
you know we should do go all the way
across town cuz we also don't like gay
people to get our you know our chicken
sandwiches yeah I think people are so
lazy that even if the place that you
know is in their neighborhood is run by
gay people and they hate gay people
they're just hungry
and they want it delivered so you're
just going to call yeah exactly they
deliver almost everything you want on
that note in full disclosure I should
tell you that my picture actually is
yeah b-but that's for a whole other
reason okay let's keep talking about
states and what's going on in this we
have all these states in this country
and they're all just a little bit
different a new app called spreadsheets
is it's tracking your performance
between the sheets yeah
basically using users movement and audio
levels it tracks how long and the
duration that you're having sex I guess
how long in duration at the same thing
so these are the states with the longest
duration of sex New Mexico they are
doing it seven minutes and one second
long of sex West Virginia Idaho South
Carolina Missouri Michigan Utah Oregon
Nebraska and Alabama so the tenth
there's a four minute duration Bay
there's basically a three and a half
four minute difference between one and
ten in the length of sex and these are
the states with the shortest duration of
sex Louisiana Kentucky Arkansas DC
Nevada Georgia Montana Vermont South
Dakota and Alaska they are only having
now this is self-reported of course and
you have to have the app for this but
one minute and 21 seconds worth of sex
do these numbers make any sense to you
well New Mexico is supposed to be I've
never been there but I heard it's just
beautiful so seven minutes it would be
like seven minutes in heaven with the
mountains and the sky it's wonderful no
there's no state that has sex for six
minutes like 7:00 to 5:00 that six
minutes is it's in the nether there's no
six as the devil's know but one minute
Alaska one minute and 21 seconds it's
because it's so cold so okay just want
to get it over with
see but I thought it was the reverse in
Alaska it seems like you would want the
body warm just to avoid the hypothermia
wouldn't you be having more sex they
might have sex 15 times in a row Oh in
each instance last one minute twenty-one
seconds I think there's a reporting
error perhaps yeah 15 is a bit excessive
cell phone worked scientific cuz you
basically have to have an iPhone in the
app you have to be willing to record
yourself and all that kind of stuff
21 seconds those people seemed great at
sex there's no efficient these people in
New Mexico like alright honey whatever I
do I put it again huh I moved from
Massachusetts to California yeah I
gained seven seconds in the bedroom yeah
and do you feel your sex life is better
here in California it was in
Massachusetts I have no idea what I
think it's really interesting
I wondered if those numbers included
foreplay or if that was just oh that is
a good question yeah you were thinking
the same thing I was wondering because
you start going where is there chocolate
my husband cleaning up I think that
extra seven seconds is me getting the
towel by the way we should tell you guys
that New York is ranked 23rd at 301 and
California at 238 they're ranked 32nd
where really though where does this fall
into your sex these all these numbers
seem incredibly low to me 7 minutes
that's the longest I mean 7 minutes for
me you know that would be very very
short how long you've been in a
relationship because like I feel like
any second spend spent trying to have
sex with my girlfriend is me
inconveniencing her and at this point if
she's like let's go visit people in
Alaska let's just get you over with as
fast as possible yeah that's your code
Alaska yeah hurry it up
yeah where do you want to go tonight
sweetheart Alaska or near Alaska yeah
now where do you I believe are the one
married panelist Here I am how does sex
how does that fit into the married life
is it like I've got to do this because
we have to do this a certain amount of
time per week I could be more loaded
quick I would much rather get a massage
you are the massage at almost 53 know
what how do i I don't know it's a very
personal very um but let's just say
seven minutes is I guess that's average
that average but as
said bread it depends on how many times
yeah yeah I like to think this is not a
very popular app so maybe the white
person who has this app in New Mexico
just takes longer than the one person
who has this app like there is like
someone who's like in their 30s in New
Mexico has it doesn't really finish as
fast as they used to and then there's
like a a 19 year old in Alaska who's
like I'm finished already let's move on
yeah all right well we provided you with
a very unscientific analysis of a very
unscientific poll on sex duration okay
let's talk about 2016 because they don't
talk about that enough on cable news do
they you guys remember
Ralph Nader he runs for president every
couple years screws up the whole thing
maybe Al Gore would be the president see
he loves seat belts especially in the
70s yeah we could have had Algor perhaps
who knows so he came out with an
interesting memo outlining 20 people
that he calls moderately enlightened
rich people mercs that he thinks could
run for president in 2016 and that might
actually be decent
okay so here's some of the people on the
list you got have Oprah on any list of
rich people that are doing things we got
Bill Gates Ted Turner former third party
New York Governor candidate Tom Golisano
and former AOL chief executive Steve
Case and let's get we've got a quote of
Nader explaining why he thinks these
merps
could lead us into the future presently
only very rich modestly enlightened
people could have a chance to break this
introverted cycle of political oligarchy
which unenlightened rich people
generally approve of that sets its own
rules makes its own laws and appoints
its own judges and even brazenly forces
tax payers to finance its quadrennial
political conventions Ralph Nader should
probably maybe use a period and
occasionally InnoCentive to explain
something that would have been easier
for me could use a different end a
little more makeup when he's on TV all
right but let's not make this about
Nader it is our only chance
to break the system this endless money
machine system could it possibly be true
that a billionaire self financing his
campaign might actually be the one
chance we have
to get money out of politics as reverses
that sounds well he wants to crack open
the system let somebody else in so that
the same people don't get elected and
the same corporations don't keep
donating right so maybe having a third
party somebody like a I was gonna say
Madonna I met Oprah I mean honestly I
would vote for Bill Maher or Jon Stewart
or even somebody like Beyonce because
other dignitaries from other foreign
countries would love to sit down with a
Beyonce and people would say I don't
know that she quite qualifies on the
billionaire list but maybe she's on her
way over Beyonce total dollar amount
when they put them together as the power
couple maybe that crack civilian yeah I
do think collectively you know people
running for president might you know be
able to collectively raise a billion
dollars so what's the difference I think
the sad part about if you have a
moderately enlightened billionaire I
think the very enlightened billionaires
are the ones are like forget politics I
don't know but isn't that the truth like
you were really forget about how much
money you have but if you were really an
enlightened person would you ever want
to run for political office marianne
williamson is running and she's a very
enlightened I don't even know who she is
so she must be very enlightening she
speaks a lot about love and she's more
of a like a spiritual leader but she's
running for some seat somewhere right
now so but like Al Franken kind of did
that he cracked it open because it made
the media paid attention to him so I
think it's less about the money and more
about can you get new life into politics
yeah is it just a sad state of American
politics though that we might need a
billionaire to actually get money out I
yeah I don't think so I think the sadder
thing is if you are this moderately
enlightened billionaire who is going to
try and run you're not going to win the
presidency that is a fact I mean I just
don't see it happening
even if Oprah throws or her you know had
in the ring
I think what that accomplishes is what
inator accomplished and what Perrault
accomplished which means the person
who's actually closest to you on the
political spectrum loses because of you
yeah so I just think the third party
system Al Gore right you know George
Bush like that is those are things that
arguably lost the election any other
decisions could have been made but
largely you know lost the election for
the person who was closed on the
political spectrum to the billionaire
who ran yeah or the large third runs
within a party I think that helps with
the picnic party like make it fun I mean
whoever the billionaire is it's going to
be a great party they're so serious all
the time and all that but the picnic
party is pleasant maybe champagne yeah
something like those like $5,000 a plate
dinners like the billionaire puts $5,000
on your plate that's pretty good
yeah I'm still getting email from the
Obama campaign
oh yeah asking me for money I don't that
I don't understand I'm trying to pay my
health care yeah well they have to usher
in the 2014 candidates that he likes to
it just say right but that's the problem
it's just a never-ending cycle but isn't
also part problem here is that we have
this like thing where now people are
really hating rich people rightly or
wrongly so the idea of a billionaire
self-funded candidate if Michael
Bloomberg suddenly ran for president
wouldn't the populist who they would
hate that right also the Republican side
doesn't need that because the Republican
side they're a lot of the money comes
from corporate interests anyway so like
the business minded person running on
the Republican side that's not new
that's not getting the the corporate
money I mean like 52 percent to forty
eight percent or something like I don't
know the corporate money is one thing
but I think these moderately enlightened
candidates that Mader's mentioning are
all or for a lot in a large part like
big democratically than what they what I
think he means by enlightened is is the
person for whose money they put into
politics isn't expecting money to come
directly back to their cause or company
that's what he means
a billionaire right but there's other
people who are just like you know I'm
gonna give you money for my you know
shoelace making corporation so we can
have my kind of shoelace
go to like every school kid in Atlanta
see I think it's a good idea to start
the conversation about it I'm not
necessarily I don't know if I agree with
the title MERP I think that's a very
Ralph Nader moderately rich brand picnic
yeah all right so last thought on this
can we ever get the money out I mean we
do some story about this every week
since we've been doing this show but
thinking the root of this is just the
ridiculous amount of money in politics
and you know I've now presented this
question three times but the idea even
how silly it is that you need a
billionaire to come in so that the money
could get out is there any chance that
the system will ever change no no no I
do I actually think this is elevating
the conversation so maybe because
democracy doesn't work right now yeah I
just bring us home if the politician
runs who is not for sale there's someone
on the other side who is and it will
kind of activate people to over fun you
know you get one billionaire running
against you know 25 billionaires giving
to the other side it's it's tough
I think our candidate is gonna be from
New Mexico and happy that's there
actually all right let's move on to fast
food the fast food story of the week
this is really interesting so a
chiropractor in Nebraska he has been
displaying a two-year-old McDonald's
Happy Meal in his office as a way of
hoping that it'll show his patients to
eat healthier there it is so that's two
years old that looks pretty pretty
similar to it to a two hour old
Happy Meal doesn't it I mean that
doesn't look that different right this
is really the air is it it's exposed at
cetera et cetera to be fair the guy put
it in one of those cake domes right but
it's not completely right that's not
airtight a something I made muffins once
and put
yeah for like three weeks they were fine
they were like still moist and fantastic
so I need two two years or so but I
think this is more a commercial for the
cake dough so this is ironically he's
selling cake domes on the side there's a
slight difference between the three week
old muffin is thought through respect to
your muffins in the cake dome then the
you know the two-year-old McDonald's but
we also have any image this one's wild
this is a 14 year old McDonald's Happy
Meal yeah now 14 years old it by all
logic we would all think it would be
rotted and molded and pretty much fun
guide and give me another word really
odorous and decompose and nasta fide but
it is not now we should say here that
McDonald's has acknowledged that these
burgers don't rot and claims the food
are dehydrated so they don't rot in the
absence of water therefore claiming is
an abundance of chemicals that's doing
this now we've also talked about
McDonald's pink slime and the burgers
and last week we did the story about the
yoga mat chemical that is in all the
breads at all the fast food places and
every time we do a story on this people
in the comment section go crazy saying
well we have chemicals and everything
and it said that you shouldn't have too
much of the chemical but if you want a
little yoga mat chemical in your bread
then that's okay is that that so that
argument could we just just talk about
that argument yes we have chemicals in
everything and we're constantly inhaling
all kinds of things and at one time
people thought asbestos was okay and bla
bla bla but shouldn't we have just like
a basic rule that you don't need these
things even if we even if there's
somehow sort of harmless now that we
don't need yoga mat chemicals that
expand elasticity and that's why they
put it in the bread and that's why the
subway bread is so am I in my wild
radical when I say that no I I mean I've
heard of like metal fillings being in
like Wheaties and stuff like you're
holding magnets up to them and I know so
what is except what's the acceptable
level of or that I'm eating know if the
food doesn't
compose I don't think I should put it in
my body that said there was a receipt
somebody was showing a receipt it cost
like 79 cents 14 years ago for that
hamburger the receipt was decomposing so
basically it would be healthier to eat
the receipt yeah then it would to eat
the patty what do you say to these
people who say science and it's if you
don't have too much of the chemical I
would like to see them dehydrate a piece
of grade-a sirloin
you know and see if that holds up as
well as as the pink slime post 14 years
also I'd like to meet this guy who kept
a burger for 14 years right you gotta
wonder about that did he do it on
purpose I drove by McDonald's yesterday
said billions and billions served and I
was thinking there are billions and
billions of those hamburger patties in
the universe somewhere so it's like
Cloudy with a Chance of hamburger a bit
of whoppers or whenever therefore well
speaking of billions billions served
there was also a thing that came out
today that McDonald's has right now I
kid you not
10 million extra pounds of chicken wings
their mighty wings they're not selling
so they have 10 million extra pounds is
this just like a whole problem with our
it's our food source and why and all the
whole fat it's just like the whole
socio-economic thing and is a big know
what people aren't even mighty wing you
like the mighty way yeah research they
didn't do the research enough to know
that people wouldn't eat the might even
yeah is McDonald's here's people saying
listen you don't serve actual food in
your happy meal it is a miserable meal
and the and so they try to give you now
their menus are bright and green if you
look at the McDonald's breakfast menu on
the drive-through window everything's on
plates which has never happened to an
Egg McMuffin no one's like okay let me
put it on a plate and have a nice cup of
coffee that I pour my you know
McDonald's coffee into right and then
there's leafy greens now as opposed to
the shredded lettuce that they've had on
things in the past and so for the mighty
wing they wanted it to look like an
actual animal part and people are like
no I
fine I don't care I like that sometimes
it's like a game when I bite the
McNugget when am I gonna get that like
gelatinous unsure above all from
spinning the chicken in a circle and
taking whatever [ __ ] sticks to the
outside and putting it in a nugget
whatever clitoris whatever it looks like
I just want to eat chicken cleaner and
if we can make that happen actually some
of the mighty wings kind of do look like
a big quick fast food that is slow to
decompose yeah so you get it in fast and
never personal weight because I don't
think the clitoris stories personally
baskin-robbins ice cream cake doesn't
melt
I left my intimate chocalate cheap no
songs dome out of the dome in my kitchen
I like had a party in a cake and I got
drunk and went to sleep and I came back
the next morning to the kitchen and it
is just this this large sponge it is it
it yes it kind of deflate s' but that
ice cream you would imagine would melt
and it just does not Wow
so there's something you know so she
hydrated ice cream cream
all right so final thought on this so
everyone always says well if you
Americans if you want your food cheap
and you want it fast well then we have
to put all this stuff in there and
that's and then they also say well if
you know the people that are in the
lower end of the economic scale that
they can only afford this stuff but I
don't even think that argument makes any
sense because it doesn't a happy meal or
a number-one and Big Mac meal cost
around seven or eight bucks in
McDonald's and my ballpark UNIX mascot
the wrong person yeah McDonald's lover
typically got 650 okay then come out for
six minutes
so 650 couldn't you for 650 go to Trader
Joe's I know there's not Trader Joe's
everywhere like there is a McDonald's
but get not only a healthy meal for 650
but more than one meal you get a bag of
kale for a moment about Trader Joe's am
I in there and they're in their sodium
bricks that they everyone's the cheap
special Trader Joe's is frozen stuff
that's the cheap stuff at Trader Joe's
and that is not good for you but you
could get a bag of kale at Trader Joe's
for like two bucks and a wrap that's
basically you put it on a plate and eat
that and it would be the same price so
does that economic or am I just being
I'm being you try being an elitist you
tried to park it trader do it really is
a question of convenience yeah right
that that's why people drive through
I'll have number one it's so much easier
than yeah you just came up with so
Trader Joe's had the drive-thru we might
have solved something here I just think
your problem is that you just told
America to eat its vegetables yeah I
apologize I retract that whole thing I
completely apologize about that so
there's a new project called bubbles and
it's aiming to create urban parks inside
a giant bubble this really reminds me I
don't know if you guys played Sim City
back in the day but when you got into
the future in Sim City the deep future
like 2050 everything soared I looked
like this so we've got a couple more
images of these things and this is
through or project which is designed as
a response to rising pollution affecting
cities in Asia and it's got a way that
it's gonna filter air flowing inside
parks while controlling temperature and
humidity you know look this sort of
seems like I mean this all looks like
the future to me it looks a little bit
like Elysium you know this in this
future where you know the ozone layer
has been depleted and we gotta watch out
for the Sun and our air is no good and
all that stuff are we gonna be bubble
people is it is everyone gonna be a
bubble boy like in Seinfeld
rolling around or Pauly Shore and
biodome yeah well so this is biodome
this is basically it's being under your
cake dome I mean it all came around is
this the future really I mean we can't
stop climate change right so why don't
we just manage it and live in bubbles
see as long as only the wealthy can use
it I'm fine with it because right now
this is essentially like putting a roof
over the open air shelter that is the
the public park mm-hmm and I just think
this is gonna make homeless people too
comfortable
that's the problem that's the thing is
like I mean yeah you're gonna know I
think we need to like yes make parks
more livable and I think instead of just
putting a dome over them we need to fix
the pollution problem rice is putting a
very strange-looking soap and water
band-aid over a much larger wound right
so it seems to me that what they're
doing here is they're sort of giving up
on the idea that we can reverse climate
change or fix it which and that's what
scientists are saying now we can't go
back so we may as well do these types of
things and be growing our agriculture in
these domes and and all that is it too
late to fix climate change um no I
actually I think don't we need don't
people need antibodies or they need to
be out in nature nor energy watch goes
hey so bubble people will never if it
were bubble wrap that would that would
be fun for the birds we're like oh look
at all those trees thunk and they're
just like face-first on this strange
bubble they have to get in the bubble
like they do I've seen birds at the
airport from the simpsons movie so we
want to keep out the idiot birds and
only breed very smart birds yeah we we
put the dome over the top and only the
ones who are wise enough to get in birds
that don't like people the call back
Queen right all together yeah this gonna
lead us to other planets you think
that's gonna be the thing maybe we won't
get it quite right here or we'll do it
here for a little bit but that's gonna
be the trick of how we end up living on
Mars or on Pandora from Avatar or
something pretty much we're gonna end up
in domes on other planets yes you're on
board domes on other planets Inc domes
on other planets and I'm only behind
this bubble thing if the way you make it
is you take a huge one of those like big
bubble wands that like surprises
children and someone just like you put
it like the Statue of Liberty's hand
from ghostbusters 2 it just kind of yeah
we should get Harold Ramis a little
shout out I did pass away this week one
of the great comedy legends where do you
think the first dome is gonna pop up I'm
thinking this has to be
like a Brooklyn like hipsters are gonna
want to live in a dome and then it'll
become cool for a little while and then
everyone want out of it I think South by
Southwest yeah that'll be the first dome
will definitely debut some festival from
there you have a dome I think yeah yeah
South by Southwest and they'll take the
homeless people who are in the park and
turn them into mobile hotspots outside
of the park as long as we're talking
future we've talked a little bit about
Ray Kurzweil he is the director of
engineering and the world's leading
futurologists the director engineering
at Google I should say and he believes
that computers and robots will be much
smarter than us by 2029
by 2029 computers and robots will be
able to understand what we say learn
from experience and outsmart even the
most intelligent humans they'll be able
to crack jokes Wendy we're out of a gig
they'll be able to tell stories and
they'll be able to flirt and now we have
a quote from Ray himself and today I'm
pretty much at the median of what
artificial intelligence experts think
and the public is kind of with them
because the public has seen things like
Siri where you can talk to a computer
maybe they've seen the Google
self-driving cars my views are not
radical anymore
I've actually stayed consistent it's the
rest of the world that's changing its
view now this guy is the leading
futurist in the world he believes he's
doing this thing right now we did
another story on it where he's trying to
live forever using the system of
vitamins and they're you know they have
these pills now that can go into your
body and look around and baptize
vaporise diseases and nanotechnology and
nano BOTS and all that stuff so this guy
knows what he's talking about 2029 our
robots gonna take over is that does that
seem like a rough estimate of a year
that makes sense to you I don't I don't
know I just want the robot to be able to
load my dishwasher for me not be a very
happy person I actually did get to speak
with woz once and he told me he was
skeptical about the singularity but he
met with Kurzweil and by the end of
their conversation he was totally
convinced
that at some point computers and robots
will be able to take over or have the
same processes that humans do but will
they be able to change a diaper
you know like flirting one thing but
could they change my oil that makes you
order now wise you are talking about
Steve Wozniak I am former founder of
Microsoft people created the computer
yeah he was Steve Jobs like right-hand
man basically 20:29 does that seem like
the right to figure out how robots and
computers aren't smarter than us now are
they maybe they are my auto bill pay
never forgets to pay my bill I'm often
the person who forgets to do that and
everyone's always afraid in this moment
when you know robots are better than us
they'll start to kill us yeah like
robots can kill us now like drone form
there I kind of need 2029 to come around
so that robots are sophisticated enough
to feel bad about it
ah so you want robot guilt that probably
won't kick in till around 20 34 yeah
yeah I mean I definitely have a belief
that like the future is gonna be some
combo with like iRobot and the matrix
and maybe a little Minority Report and
her yeah robots yeah her he falls in
love with it like you can have sex with
a robot now yeah you think you can have
sex with such as such as the
accommodator
forget what it's called but I don't know
if you watch Howard Stern there's always
some machine that you would listen to
someone at least listen to Howard Stern
listen to someone have sex with a robot
I'm just saying the future is now yeah
what we've done stories on robot sex but
is it is it just paranoia that this is
always gonna go poorly because all the
science fiction movies yeah they always
turn on us they kill us is that just is
there a chance that some of this
actually will be good I think Ray
Kurzweil would argue if the robots could
do all the mundane tasks of the
dishwasher and the bill pay that it will
actually free up other parts of the
human brain to do things and think about
things that we don't have time for
anymore I started doing stand-up comedy
before gps's
so I literally would be more nervous
finding the place than I was actually
performing yeah so that has freed me up
the robot or whatever technology has
freed me up to be more creative so like
if somebody could drive me the Google
car is gonna come out soon that will
free me up to play candy crush it yeah
that was actually I mean that's true
like I can do I mean I remember doing
gigs and having nut drive in upstate New
York having no freaking idea where I was
going no GPS then I get on stage and I'm
like dripping with sweat I'm already
late yeah I mean do you think it could
free up some time for our brains to be
some other good stuff it will it will
open to candy crush if you like clothes
maybe I got very far and then it was
ruining my life so I deleted it and then
three days ago I put it back on so then
using the candy crush example is this
proof that all of this is good and bad
because the robots maybe can do things
that'll be great and maybe able to do
medical procedures that'll be wonderful
but then at the same time we're all
gonna get dumb because of candy crush
and is it flappy bird or fappy bird I
always but that's somebody's yeah that
one disappeared I was playing the other
one I mean it literally made tiny dumber
so are they gonna make us dumber are
they gonna make us dumber with
technology and then also the robots will
keep getting smarter I don't think those
games make me dumber that's my story and
I'm sticking to it I think it makes me
think in a different way and but don't
text and drive
you're right I shouldn't drive and drive
sure yeah I think it's it's it's it
remains to be seen yeah that's what the
future
robots the jobs robots can do are
replacing like low-paying jobs so I
don't I think they're still going to be
people who have to do for you know until
2029 they're people who have to do like
the high-paying jobs still and I'm
pretty sure that they will not
Commission the design of a robot that
allows their own job to be replaced I
think also one other things yeah like
you know how Facebook used to be the
Facebook and then the guy from Napster
came in and talked him out of the the
Facebook I think the singularity is just
gonna be called singularity that's my
prediction
singularity I mean it sounds it sounds
kind of singular alright people well
don't forget that if one day a robot
that looks like Arnold Schwarzenegger
shows up at your door asking for John
Connor I warned you about it here I want
to thank Wendy Liebman brett erlich
there Twitterers are down below don't
forget to subscribe they tell me to say
that every week and we will do this
again next week barring a robot
revolution all right